hi there i'm sam hewn hi i'm katrina
bell my name is caesar donboy uh i'm
sophie i'm lauren lyle hey i'm chris
branken and i'm losing my mind
we are the cast of outlander and we are
playing outlander cast who's who
who is most like their character on
outlander richard richard
[Laughter]
rolo
rolo i was gonna say rollo
method acting actually who is least like
their character
yeah yes sam yeah who's most likely to
accidentally go home with a kilt from
the costume department john bell
john doesn't wear it doesn't wear a kill
but i'm sure he goes home with some of
the the yeah i reckon he's a klepto yeah
he's still stuff sam
says are you trying to steal clothes all
the time yeah but that's the thing i
never wear a kilt that's the problem
wait lauren didn't you steal something
from the set no no
oh don't we all no who's most likely to
host a podcast about scottish highland
history damn
sam
me i guess but i don't really know
anything about it who's most likely to
be caught snacking at craft services
sophie did you say sophie yeah sophie
yes
i often get in trouble that there's a
rustle on my mic pack and it's usually
because i have snacks in my pockets who
is most likely to laugh in the middle of
a serious take katrina
and it's you you
it is me yeah who's most likely to host
a dinner party for the rest of the cast
me john
now katrina me
yes yes you've hosted a number of
i do like toast a bit of a dinner party
yeah i remember you did one for my
birthday we had amazing tacos who's most
likely to direct an episode of outlander
next season
wrong i was about to say reloading
the safest answer
nobody no one
all right who is most likely to nail a
monologue on the first take me rolo
yeah
david you
oh david yeah who's most likely to give
the best life advice
katrina
i'd say you give a lot of good life
advice sometimes it's not always i've
been around the longest that's why says
you are good you're good at life advice
i give you some
you've got your great numbers
you've got me through some really some
tough times with your metaphors about my
favorite metaphor that cesar's ever had
about life is
when he described when like we were both
feeling a lot of things and he was
talking at me and he was like you know
what right now you're just a washing
machine of emotions
who's most likely to win a game of
outlander trivia dumbbell probably you
sophie i wish that was the case i will
absolutely take that who's best at doing
impressions of current or past cast
members
i would i'd say he's a past cast member
but probably because i'm working with
him right now but mctavish is actually
does he do a good impression of us well
he does do a lot of impressions not very
good even
yet sam's actually really good at
impressions though i think i'm good at
them too i'm gonna go on a limb do me do
me how do you view for french
i don't speak like that in the show come
on have you watched the episodes um
amy lord villarreal
[Laughter]
who is most likely to send a funny meme
or tick-tock to the cast group chat
lauren
oh yeah richard your invitation's
pending i think oh what do we have a
cast group chat
no why don't we we should have a cars
group chat i think maybe the youngans do
maybe we're just not part of it but i
wouldn't say anyone invited
probably we're probably too uh
uncool but i would say probably either
says or lauren
yes probably cesar and lauren who's most
likely to sing the outlander theme tune
during karaoke the whole card
a little cast there you go
i feel like the whole class we all kind
of break into that sometimes
um but jb also would probably take a
solo
uh a stab at it john bell i used to do a
nice
and then not do it
that really made it what works is that
you have a you have to have a sound
coming from one cheek and then the other
one from the other one that's how you
get the pipes you know
wow it's it's stunning thank you
buzzfeed and everyone make sure to watch
the new season of outlander bye buzzfeed
thank you guys
[Music]
[Music]